deep learning algorithms have a huge
hunger for training data
they just often work best we can find
enough labor training data to put into
the training center
this is resulted in many teams sometimes
taking one of the days you can find and
just shoving it into the training set
just to get more training data even as
some of this data or even if maybe a lot
of this data doesn't come from the same
distribution as your def and test data
so in a deep learning error more and
more teams are now training on data that
comes from a different distribution than
your depth and test set and there's some
subtleties and some best practices but
dealing with when you train and test
distributions differ from each other
let's take a look not say that you're
building a mobile app where users will
upload pictures take from the cell
phones and you want to recognize whether
the picture is that your users upload
from the mobile app is a cat or not so
you can now get two sources of data one
which is the distribution of data you
really care about this data from a
mobile app like that on the right which
tends to be less professionally shots
less warframe maybe the blurrier to the
short pipe you know amateur users the
other source of data you can get is you
can crawl the web and just download a
lot of them for the sake of this example
let's you can download a lot of very
professional trains high-resolution
professionally taken images of cats and
let's say you don't have a lot of users
yet for your mobile apps so maybe you've
gotten you know 10,000 pictures uploaded
from the mobile app but by crawling the
web you can download huge numbers of cat
pictures and maybe you have 200,000
pictures of cats downloaded off the
internet so what you really care about
is that your final system does well on
the mobile app distribution of images
right because in the end your users be
uploading pictures like those on the
right and you need your classifier to do
well on that but you now have a bit of a
dilemma because you have a relatively
small data set just 10,000 examples
drawn from that distribution
and you have a much bigger data set
that's drawn from a different
distribution a different appearance of
image than the one you actually want so
you don't want to use just those 10,000
images because it ends up giving you a
relatively small training set and using
this 200,000 images seems helpful but
you know the dilemma is this 200,000
images isn't from exactly the
distribution you want so what can you do
well here's one option one thing to do
is put both of these datasets together
so you now have two hundred and ten
thousand images and you can then take
the two hundred ten thousand images and
randomly shuffle them into a train
death and test set and let's say for the
sake of argument that you decided that
your death in test says will be two
thousand five hundred examples each so
your training sets will be two hundred
and five thousand examples now so some
of your data this way it has some
advantages but also disadvantages the
advantage is that now your training
depth and test sets will all come from
the same distribution so that makes it
easier to manage
but the disadvantage and this is a huge
disadvantage is that if you look at your
def set of this 2500 examples a lot of
it will come from the web page
distribution of images rather than what
you actually care about which is the
mobile app distribution of images so it
turns out that of your total amount of
data two hundred thousand rebate at 200k
out of two hundred and ten thousand to
the regular 210 K that comes from
webpages so all of this 2500 examples on
expectation I think two hundred two
thousand three hundred and eighty one of
them will come from webpages this is on
expectation the exact number will vary
around this depending on how the random
shuffle operation went but on average
only a hundred and nineteen will come
from mobile app up
so remember that said you have the death
set is telling your team where to aim to
target and the way your England target
you're saying spend most of the time
optimizing for the webpage distribution
of images which is really not what you
want so I would recommend against option
one because this is setting up the death
set to tell your team to optimize for a
different distribution of data than what
you actually care about so instead of
doing this I would recommend that you
instead take another option which is the
following the training set let's say
it's still two hundred five thousand
images I would have the training set
have two hundred thousand all two
hundred thousand images from the web and
then you can if you want add in five
thousand images from the mobile app and
then for your dev and test sets
I guess my data sets eyes on terms of
scale your dev and test sets would be
all mobile app images so the training
set will include two hundred thousand
images from the web and five thousand
from the mobile app the death set will
be 2500 images from the mobile app and
the test set will be 2500 images also
from the mobile app the advantage of
this way of splitting up your data to
Train dev and test is that you're now
aiming the target where you want it to
be you're telling your team my dev set
has data uploaded from the mobile app
and that's the distribution of images
you really care about so let's try to
build a machine learning system that
does really well on the mobile app
distribution of images
the disadvantage of course is that now
your training distribution is different
from your dev intensity distributions
but it turns out that this split of your
data into training dev and test will get
you better performance over the long
term and we'll discuss later
some specific techniques for dealing
with your training set coming from
different distributions and your dev and
test sets let's look at another example
let's say you're building a brand new
product a speech activated rear view
mirror for a call so this is a real
product in China is making its way into
other countries but you can build a rear
view mirror to replace this little thing
there so that you can now talk to the
rear view mirror and basically say dear
rear view mirror please help me find
navigational directions and yours gas
station and a view with it so this is
actually a real problem and let's say
you're trying to build this for your own
country so how can you get data to train
up a speech recognition system for this
product well maybe if work on speech
recognition for a long time so you have
a lot of data from other speech
recognition applications just not from a
speech activated rear view mirror
here's how you could split up your
training and your deaf intestines so for
a training you can take all the speech
data you have that your accumulated from
work on other speech problems such as
data you purchased over the years from
various speech recognition data vendors
and today you can actually buy data from
vendors of your X Y parents where X is
an audio clip and Y is a transcript or
maybe you've worked on smart speakers
smart voice activated speakers so you
have some data from that maybe it worked
on voice activated keyboards and so on
and for the sake of argument maybe you
have half a million utterances from all
of these sources and for your dev and
test set maybe of a much smaller data
set that actually came from a speech
activated rear view mirror you know
because users are asking for
navigational queries or trying to find
directions in these places this data set
will maybe have a lot more street
addresses right please help me navigate
to this screen hydrogen so please help
me navigate to this gas station
so this distribution of data will be
very different than these on the left
but this is really the data you care
about because this is what you need your
product to do well on so this is what
you send your death and then test that
to be so what you do in this example is
set your training set to be the five
hundred thousand observances on the left
and then your dev and test sets which
I'll abbreviate D and T these could be
maybe ten thousand other isms each
that's drawn from actual the speech
activated rearview mirror or
alternatively if you think you don't
need to put all twenty thousand examples
from your speech activated rearview
mirror into the dev and test sets maybe
you can take half of that and put that
in the training set so then the training
set could be five hundred and ten
thousand utterances including all five
hundred from there and ten thousand from
the rearview mirror and then the Deaf in
test sets could maybe be on five
thousand dollar and so huge so up to
twenty thousand other answers may be ten
K goes into the training set and five K
into the death set in five K five
thousand into the test set so this would
be another reasonable way of splitting
your data into trained deaf intense and
this gives you a much bigger training
set over five thousand other answers
then you were to only use speech
activated rearview mirror data for your
training set so in this video you've
seen a couple examples of when allowing
your training set data to come from a
different distribution then your Devon
test set allows you to have much more
training data and in these examples and
it will cause your learning algorithms
perform better now one question might
ask is should always use all the data
you have the answer is subtle there's
not always yes let's look at the counter
example in the next video